and let know whether I should be happy
or concerned that hosaka is looking at
the subscribe button for the new world
review like this I mean on the one hand
it's understandable because it does give
you regular hunt on to content upload it
straight into your YouTube feed but then
again he is almost certainly going to
try to bang it so I recommend that you
all press it pretty quickly before that
happens hello and welcome to the new
order video source for everything anime
and manga and today I would like to take
the time to discuss one of my favorite
characters in hunt hunter and more
specifically attempt to break down why
he is such a beloved presence in the
series because if you look at everything
that is Hisoka on paper it kind of goes
against well everything that we as a
global society tend to value and put it
plainly he is a selfish mass murdering
outsider with proudly displayed extreme
intimate tendencies aka weird sexual
fetishes in the real world someone like
you soca would be ostracized from
society for so so many different reasons
and to be fair that is kind of reflected
in Hunter hunter because he Sokka is
generally separate from the world at
large but for some reason within the
context of reading or watching a story I
find him to be endlessly fascinating and
look forward to his presence far more
than a large majority of the cast and I
think this opening post from an old
reddit thread by King Pharaoh dem that I
stumbled upon really sums up the grand
question that I am asking in this video
I'm a huge fan of Hisoka and the wake he
leaves in his quest for the ultimate
fight he's the embodiment of what Ching
was talking about in the election art
the more unpredictable the opponent's
motives the more dangerous they become
but it occurs to me that if he Sokka
happened to move into my house on my
street I'd likely call the police why
are we so attracted to the dangerous
Psychopaths and that is our dilemma
why are we so endlessly captivated by
figure that we would never under any
circumstances want in our own lives and
there's a lot of profound psychological
reasoning for this and it doesn't just
go for Hisoka he is but one example of a
compelling figure like this another
would be the character Dexter well if we
remain in keeping with the world of
anime and manga then all Akkad from
Helsing would be another figure that
inspires that same slot of compelling
presence well you know actually even the
entire genre of true crime which takes
real-life figures and can tell some very
disturbing stories that hit home pretty
hard and yet they're so damn compelling
and there's a lot of reasons for the
popularity of this sort of material one
of which I'm certain you've heard before
which is the old quote of home
it was like a train wreck and just
couldn't look away which makes to some
sort of morbid fascination which
definitely applies to soca the idea that
you know what's happening is not good
not good at all
which is the large majority if he saw
his actions but at the same time this is
something very unusual to see in life
and the basic desire for experience
overrides everything else and part of
that can be explained by the idea that
deep down humans can actually find some
sort of evolutionary benefit from
watching these situations thinking that
they can learn and be better prepared if
they were to encounter said situations
in their own lives
of course how effective this can be is
very debatable and applying a tea Soaker
is it's not going to work out very well
because you can watch as many examples
of Bunji come as you like you'd still be
pretty screwed if you ran into Soaker in
a dark alleyway or even a perfectly lit
alleyway it really wouldn't matter but
the third and final base response I
think is the most profoundly engaging
one which is the simple idea of an
adrenaline rush which obviously is
nowhere near say the scale of skydiving
but experiencing any form of well
portrayed danger in media does still
release a bit of the old hormones and
that can become quite addicting meaning
that I believe it's honestly possible
for readers or Watchers of Hunter hunter
to become somewhat chemically addicted
to Hisoka because he provides that sense
of potential danger wherever he pops up
even if he ends up doing absolutely
nothing but we need to dive a lot deeper
than that
it's very easy to say the effect that he
soca provides but what I'm much more
interested in is how togarashi has
crafted him to do so and the first
factor I'd like to examine is that of
mystery mystery is a fascinating human
phenomena that appeals to our innate
curiosity a lustful answers is pretty
unparalleled in all of existence as we
know it and Hisoka is effectively a
walking question mark he struts into the
series with a bold design twisted
desires and the power to make them a
reality even if you are not consciously
aware of it there is a desire to know
what circumstances forged a person like
this and yes I know that is a Hisoka
back story chapter which I will address
in a bit but focusing solely on the
Canon of hunt hunter this has not and is
unlikely to ever be revealed and I would
like and he soaked has appealed to that
of you know quite probably the most
infamous villain of all time in media
being the Joker a character who has been
featured in comic shows and films for 80
years now and despite the fact that
there have been a wide variety of origin
stories published there are still no
definitive answer as to what created the
Joker and I really do think that's how
the character works best with this veil
of mystery permanently hanging over him
which you can see reflected very
strongly in Hisoka there is nothing
known about his past prior to some
scattered events of him in Heaven's
arena as well as the former hunter exam
and defeating a member of the Phantom
troupe but all of that is still
relatively recent history and here is
where we will bring up the fact that
there was a one-shot storyboard chapter
completed by sweta long carved Tokyo
ghoul with Takashi's blessing that told
an origin story of Hisoka in which he as
a child joined circus discovers nan and
I won't spoil the rest for you in case
you're keen on reading it but it's a
very cool piece of media especially when
you see he so can use bungee gum for the
court unquote first time and I say quote
unquote because yeah this was made with
took ah she's approval but there has
never been a statement regarding its
kinoma C and I personally believe that
that's how it should remain just like
how the Joker has his various intriguing
origin tales
I think this chapter serves as something
of a great urban legend of how he Sokka
may have come to be but at the same time
his mystery will enjoy and never
properly be solved which results in a
permanent sense of intrigue regarding
him because this enigma will never be
unlocked and that's not the only factor
that makes an audience pay that little
bit of extra attention to him because a
mysterious origin is one thing but it
counts for very little if the actions of
the character don't reflect that and in
he soaked his case the question mark
created by his origin
transfers over to every decision we see
him make in the series which are largely
unpredictable when he so Kerr appears
you can never quite be sure what he's
going to do even if you think you
understand the character and his
motivations you still have next to zero
chance of predicting how he is going to
go about achieving those goals which
means that whenever he soaked his
presence becomes apparent you are very
much rolling the dice on how this scene
conflict or even an entire arc is going
to play out because there are points
where Hisoka can be a very random force
of anarchy and with that in mind we
always have to be very wary of Hisoka
scenes because he brings with him an
incomparable sense of tension because
things could work out very well and
he'll agree to like join your dodgeball
team to kill some time but things can
also go very very badly and resulting
grand tragedy like an iconic character
being unceremoniously murdered within
seconds and just to contrast this to
explain why this factor is so important
let's take another beloved antagonist
and hunt on top crawler he also commands
a great sense of intrigue but for
three different reasons to Hisoka
because if he soca is the ultimate force
of anarchy and krolow is the epitome of
planned destruction as a result though
general Crowley scenes don't tend to
carry the extreme tension that Hisoka
brings with him because you know the
crow Lo is extraordinarily unlikely to
act unless this action is something that
he has thought thoroughly about he isn't
a force of ground surprise usually that
is and so you can almost feel at ease
with crow low until his plan goes into
action and I'm not saying that's a bad
thing at all but he Sokka has this more
volatile factor that commands us to pay
close attention to him at all times
because he evokes unpredictable danger
in addition to this though the Hisoka
character is also able to tap into a lot
of empathy with readers and watches of
the series and at first that probably
sounds like artoo madness because how
could we possibly empathize with this
mad magician and it's less to do with
his actions which are by and large 100%
deplorable but more to do with what
those actions represent which is a grand
sense of freedom
Hisoka is a man who is not bound by the
same sort of societal conventions that
we are in the real world or even the
characters in the world of hunt hunter
Aurra he lives life entirely for himself
and to achieve his own purposes which is
something that is very very twisted ly
admirable because I'm sure that we have
all experienced a desire to break away
from the societal standards that we are
constrained into not to the point of
murder and such but for more simplistic
things like man I really wished I lived
in a world where I didn't have to pay
rent or if you're a younger man I wished
I lived in a world where I didn't have
to do homework or whatever it is the
kids do and don't want to do it's been a
while since I've been one but then comes
along Hisoka who represents a bit of an
escape from those constraints a kind of
vicarious living if you will because can
you imagine a situation where he soccer
is doing something like paying rent I
mean maybe you can because he is simply
that unpredictable but he saw her as a
character who can essentially go
anywhere he wants and do anything he
wants there are no restrictions on him
whatsoever in this world and that is
something that most people look towards
as an ideal standard of life now what
Hisoka does but those actions is
obviously questionable at the very least
but the fact that he has the freedom to
do so is also a key factor in this
segment of his appeal and also before I
get any comments like so what everyone
in Hunter hunter can do that no nor they
really cannot almost every other
character in the series has some sort of
hindrance that constrains them take on
and kill over for example their
constraint is that they
not strong enough they can't simply
wander in anywhere they like because
chances are they will get obliterated by
some sort of opponent and as strong as
they become that feeling will never be
dispelled these two boys are at the
mercy of this world whereas with the
character like you Sokka it's very much
the other way around there is this
distinct feeling that the world is very
much at his mercy because he operates on
an entirely different level for another
example though let's take Allah me the
man who undoubtedly has power equitable
to soca' but who has nowhere near the
freedom that his clown chum has because
illa meas restriction is that he exists
almost exclusively to operate the zoldak
family business so yes he can
theoretically go anywhere in the world
he wants but his actions are mandated
entirely by his family and their clients
so illa me has all of the power in the
world but very little freedom to
actually use it so he definitely doesn't
evoke anywhere near the same sort of
feeling generated by Hisoka who has this
perfect balance of both supreme power
and supreme freedom and that's obviously
not all there is to it and not
everything needs such a detailed
explanation because there is a much more
simplistic appeal to many people which
is that they enjoy Hisoka because he
just has a great character design so
their indulgence of him spawns from
aesthetics alone which I can also
appreciate and it definitely helps at
his fighting style meshes well with this
as tow gosh he made a brilliant decision
to allow him to use cons to great extent
and quite frankly there's also the fact
that he is generally one good-lookin
gent which will always inspire
admiration from a certain segment of the
population no matter how despised his
actions are that's just one of those sad
but true things about life the
better-looking you are the more you can
get away with and if you're good-looking
enough you could probably get away with
murder
quite literally in the case of Hisoka
but then again if that's all there was
to it then Hisoka would become a very
shallow experience quite quickly as well
so it is very much a combination of
everything that makes him stand out his
mysterious origins consistently
unpredictable actions a bizarre sense of
admiration for his enviable lifestyle
and all wrapped together with a
brilliant design and bam you have a
recipe to activate the core mechanisms
of human fascination
Hisoka is a train wreck a beautiful
glorious fascinating train wreck and it
is nigh on impossible to break away from
that which is why Hisoka is and quite
probably always will be one of the most
compelling characters not only in haunt
hunter but in anime and manga in general
but what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server if
you came for some more
to content and please do go and check
out some and the videos will even
subscribe to the channel for regular
huntin to Glory delivered straight until
YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time